jennifer lopez says marry me to ben
affleck all over again welcome to
entertainment tonight this time it's
going down at bin's massive mansion in
riceboro georgia and et's brooke
anderson is there with every single
detail on beniver's i do's round two
thanks kevin and michelle i'm here at
half moon marina and behind me the
stunning rivers and marshes that
surround hampton island where ben's
private and very secluded estate is
located now the view from his place it's
kind of like this all right the wedding
preps of course went into high gear
today the three-day event kicks off
tonight with a big rehearsal dinner
before all the fun some pre-wedding
drama an ambulance was seen leaving
ben's estate around noon the actor's
mother reportedly fell off a dock and
cut her leg then apparently found her
and called an ambulance
ben's ex jen garner is not expected this
weekend but she's reportedly supportive
of their three children being here this
was the scene today heading into ben's
estate security was tight and officers
were checking ids near the mansion
workers could be seen putting up a tent
and assembling fake trees inside
so what's on the menu for tonight's
rehearsal dinner we know ben likes to
keep it local with shrimp and flounder
caught nearby i spoke this morning with
chef jerome at his old school diner he
and ben have known each other for nearly
two decades do you expect him this
weekend a hundred percent
j.lo you know she's got some moves so i
think it might be quite the party if
they do a late night here this weekend
they can have as long as they want
chef jerome says ben even got behind the
grill he got on the grill and tossed up
some shrimps and stuff for me
as for who will be officiating the big
ideas e.t has learned jayla's friend
author and life coach jay shetty will do
the honors last year j-lo appeared on
his podcast on purpose i was doing all
these things in like my personal
relationships it didn't seem like i was
loving myself
now when it comes to celebrating their
marriage at bench georgia estate it's
kind of a full circle moment ben bought
the house back in 2003 when they were
dating and it is massive
back in 2004 the boston native explained
why he fell in love with the peach state
i live down south of savannah i think
it's beautiful i went and shot a movie
down there forces of nature with sandra
bullock he's gonna give us a ride
all the way to georgia and i just
totally fell in love with it and the
people are wonderful and you know i live
down this long dirt road and people are
very respectful of people's privacy and
stuff down there 23 years after that
rom-com it is art imitating life what's
down in savannah my wedding then played
a groom to be heading to his big day in
georgia at the time ben told e.t what
would make him the perfect husband what
would you do best as a husband i can fix
cars cooking not a strong point i'm a
i'm a kind of a takeout guy
if a woman likes slovenlyness she's
found the right fella and of course in
2001 j.lo played the wedding planner you
think you want to get married but you
don't as e.t saw the two had very
different stances on finding the one
do you believe in love at first sight
yeah i do you know i used to think that
okay there's one person that's your
person now i think
that that's not true sometimes you know
you meet somebody and you just kind of
know something i can't imagine that
there's like that sort of there's
somebody up there saying all right these
two are meant to be together and let's
see if they ever wind their way up
towards each other one day it'd be nice
to settle down and get married but i
guess it'll just happen naturally i have
a lot of love to give
[Music]